I'm so [ __ ] pissed I started
recording this video and honey you hit
the record button I just did it right
now [ __ ] [ __ ] hey what is going on
yeah yeah yeah shameful ask people I saw
you clipping your toenails on the dinner
table what are you doing you guys like
this I think you guys do like this like
open conversation stuff I like it too
because I like talking to you but of
course every now and then I like to go
through my facebook messages the
instagrams the emails and also the
comments below where I can answer a
couple of questions that people ask more
so if you ever have any questions or
comments that you guys want me to answer
and one of these little reply response
videos go ahead you know what go to the
tip tip tip to tap a right button come
oh no to to to to type right put new
combo no butter recently a subscriber
asked David no offense but Muriel is
really cute and I just want to know how
you got somebody as cute as her because
I would like a cute girlfriend too
ok you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] why do
people will talk to me and if my dick
got anthrax or something
like there was a prerequisite for Muriel
to date me like I had to be cute and
handsome have money well [ __ ] I have
neither so April Fool's on you what am I
the [ __ ] Hunchback the South Korea
she'll be ringing a [ __ ] bell for you
this is not a bill that's a huge dick
you know I get this question a lot and I
gotta say this is by far one of the
dumbest questions that guys ask because
you guys think that there's some certain
[ __ ] key that will fit a specific
hole that will unlock this treasure of
getting [ __ ] just just just [ __ ]
throw it at your face
there really isn't like a simple
solution to this and everybody wants to
give somebody a finite answer to this
and there it doesn't exist number one
you should really ask yourself this
unless you'd like trying to hook up with
somebody why are you so desperate to be
in a relationship if you're at the
teenager or maybe even in your early 20s
just feel it out like you think that you
know what you want out of a relationship
and obviously you don't because you
can't even get past it getting a date
first now here's the cool thing that do
message me on Facebook I saw his profile
I'm not going to say his name because
respectfully so he asked me not to but
you're going to have to take this advice
with a grain of salt number one most
dudes that I find out that have a
problem with getting girls to like them
they usually lack the typical thing
which is confidence now I'm not saying
that if you have confidence you're just
gonna NAB every single girl or guy that
comes your
[ __ ] way what I am saying is that you
just if you don't [ __ ] believe in
yourself like you don't believe that you
are a dope-ass person that person that
you're gonna try to develop this
relationship with and they're not gonna
believe it either
like Muriel can attest to this one thing
that I did have aside from breasts I had
confidence by the time I decided to date
Muriel I had gone through so many
[ __ ] dates so many rejections that I
already knew what I wanted and I didn't
like kind of doing like the Korean guy
thing for any of you out there if you
guys don't know what the Korean guy
things every Korean person can attest to
this if you ever went to a [ __ ]
Korean Church we call it the robot
syndrome it's where this [ __ ] loser
right he comes over he tries to be the
girl's friend first he put his arms
around her says oh I'll be your Bible
study teacher I'll be your spiritual
guidance and then slowly after a while
he doesn't even tell you that he likes
you and then like four or five months
later he starts like trying to hold your
hand he goes oh look come you don't wake
me and then he says oh I'm always in the
friend zone
you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] where's your
the [ __ ] friendzone you never stated
what you wanted as a relationship you
[ __ ] puss and the reason why you do
that is because you have two options
then you could say oh I'm in the friend
zone or number two you could say well I
never liked you in the first place your
amigo is just being nice to you when you
really did yeah [ __ ] dingleberry
[ __ ] but to go back to how I approached
Muriel like I remember I are on a first
date which she says it's not our first
date but it wasn't [ __ ] first date
okay
took you out to dinner to the shitty ass
vegan spot like vegan food unless it's
like Indian food or Vietnamese food why
people vegan food is a [ __ ] mistake I
don't care what y'all say y'all leave
that [ __ ] alone okay I can't even get
your own food right so but this is what
happens she rode her bike to the dinner
place we had a great time we were
laughing we were joking huh told her
that I would drop her off at her place
because it was late at night and she
drove her bike and I thought it was a
little dangerous also because I want
spend more time with her you don't burn
and then right when I dropped her off
she gave me like one of those shitty ass
friend hugs you know what I mean you
know one of those like friendzone like
we're only friends type of hug kept a
little hate the [ __ ] little it's okay
if I get that hug if we're just friends
but if I want more than that I don't
want that little we just friends hugs
we're just friends you're not gonna see
my [ __ ] ever so before I left this is
exactly what I told her hey by the way
just so you're not confused I'm not your
friend and she said she was like uh what
we're not friends I like you we're not
I'm not your friend so I'll call you
tomorrow and then we'll see where we go
from there huh and she was so caught off
guard by that because I think she was so
used to people like slow playing in and
kind of playing the field to see if
somebody likes each other no I was just
very straightforward with my feelings
and I think that confidence has really
got her interested in the first place
I'm not saying that it's gonna work a
hundred percent of the time because the
confidence only works if that person
likes you too and if they don't like you
and you're still trying to be
quote-unquote confident you're turning
into a creep now number two just by the
Facebook message alone you kind of
socially awkward you got to get out
there man and being socially awkward
usually happens is because you don't
have enough life experience and you
don't hang out around enough people who
will check your [ __ ] ass stop being so
[ __ ] weird and what I mean by that is
get out of your damn head and just chill
relax just have a conversation and be
your self but if you're a weirdo don't
don't be yourself be somebody else is a
lot cooler number three it's all a
couple pictures of you went through a
couple of the pics and you did you dress
really weird and this is coming from a
guy who wears flip-flops and socks but I
can wear flip-flops and socks now I
didn't wear that when we first started
dating because she and I are now
comfortable with each other so [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] I heard my flip-flops and
socks you don't get to wear flip-flops
and socks like you got to put your best
foot forward at least you got to give
them something to grab on man if you got
some [ __ ] up shoes and some baggy ass
weird ass pants
did you [ __ ] it doesn't matter what what
brand you wear it doesn't matter what
the Hat that you have on top of your
hand or the [ __ ] jewelry or whatever
you got to get the [ __ ] basics right
you right now you dress as if you went
into a Salvation Army bin and said hey
[ __ ] it I'm telling you man ladies can
you attest to this when you look at the
way a guy dresses isn't the first two
things that you look at is the shoes and
the pants right tell me tell me I'm not
right my last advice to you would be
what the [ __ ] does it mean that you want
a cute girlfriend why is that a
prerequisite for somebody that you're
with like I understand like we all want
to be attractive
you'll be surprised with the people that
you end up with probably isn't like
ideally what you thought you were gonna
be with and for me not so much Muriel is
[ __ ] gorgeous like to me she is one of
the most beautiful people I've ever seen
in my life you want to be with an
attractive person everybody does but
it's weird that that was like your
prerequisite it was like oh how do I get
with a cute girl I don't know dude you
got to work on yourself first the
weirdest thing that I see from guys
especially you men and like I said take
this with a grain of salt how dare you
ask a woman to look a certain way when
you look like booty bro you don't even
wash your face you know what lotion is
your face look dusty as [ __ ] it's all
offenders if you're expecting this girl
to be this like beautiful cute girl like
who the [ __ ] are you what do you look
like you know what I mean
you can't expect somebody to live this
certain standard of beauty that you have
for them but you're over here looking
like hot-ass [ __ ] unfair I don't like
that [ __ ] and unless you're balling out
your [ __ ] mind and you're looking for
an empty ass relationship we're girls
just fine as [ __ ] has no personality but
I'll suck your dick cuz you got a lot of
money then well that ain't you well
that's about it guys so until next time
make sure that you guys leave comments
below about what this guy should do
maybe give him some advice as well and
on top of that leave those comments
about what the next video should be what
I should talk about articles advice
questions whatever you want let's just
see what I can do with it because I got
to get the gaff enough
I'll suck a dick for a sandwich tip tip
to tap a ripened kimono